The Joe Rogan experience to criminalize
psychedelic about what we did.
It came through.
Oh my God.
I thought you said it didn't pass this
morning and said it didn't. 15 months ago.
Holy Shit.
Denver became the first city in
the u s to decriminalize marijuana.
Wow. Powerful Denver. Wow.
Holy Shit Man.
It passed.
Approved, measured, decriminalized
psychedelic mushrooms.
Congratulations. Amazing.
How did we think that you, Jamie? I
better information you son of a bitch.
They were staying up all
night for some reason.
They did say son of a bitch.
Jamie working with the CIA still
on official apparently though,
as opposed to it on Wednesday afternoon,
ended up pulling 51 pulled
ahead this afternoon.
That's why this morning it wasn't
a head and then they still,
they're still counting votes.
Provision the provision prohibit the city
government for using any resources to
impose criminal penalties against adults
over 21 years of age or personally his
possession. A second psilocybin. Hey,
you don't have to talk with you
and the end of a commercial.
What do you want to do? You have to get
it all out just in case. No, no, no.
This is not a disclaimer.
Something hits us and kills.
Nobody knows what the fuck
you just said. Yeah, they do.
Why are we going where the
mushrooms are illegal? Oh,
too many people who move into Denver.
Man. Too many people means a lot of space.
Who many people in move with that?
Look it up.
Look it up about Denver's
problem with our infrastructure.
They're hating how many people are
coming into their city. Listen Bro,
you moved to evergreen.
Live in the mountains like a savage.
I'll move to bracket
[inaudible] album to breakfast.
How about asking too many rooms? Coke?
Breckenridge is nice. I like brick.
Don't you want to see y'all girls yell
at or boyfriends scream out in this treat
with naked
mcass we need more money.
Is the mushroom legal Allity is that
going to be like a doctor thing?
Are they gonna like no, it's
deep criminal officer. Right? As
does is that you don't go.
You Go, you don't go to jail,
but you can't sell it legally.
It's very squirrely,
but it's what it is is step
one and that's what we need.
We needed step one and then it's also
on the ballot in California soon.
And when it's on the ballot in California,
soon it has a likelier chance here.
I think that even in Denver and more
so now the real problem is people don't
understand what it is. Right? And
they think it's just like, oh my God,
these kids are going to do,
mushrooms are going to drive off cliffs.
That's what people worry about.
You can do more testing now. Right?
Is that sort of what it helps
while they've done some tests,
Johns Hopkins University had some pretty
extensive testing that they did that
showed,
um,
real positive results with people
that had terminal illnesses where it
alleviated the worry of death.
And um,
there's some other studies
that had been run on it,
but there's so far no one
has ever instituted in the
United States at least like
a real thorough,
comprehensive clinic where you can go and
they can treat you if you have alcohol
addiction,
Ptsd,
there's a lot of different things
they could treat with psilocybin.
And it's been illegal
because it's a schedule one
substance. So all these people,
it's one of the best
things on earth to fix,
like mental barriers and
problems that you have,
especially if it was done in a controlled
clinical environment by people you
trusted and you felt safe. And that's
what a shaman is supposed to be, right?
What a shaman is supposed to be as someone
who provides you with the psychedelic
substances in a controlled
state where they,
they let you be in a good state of
mind set and setting is always very,
very important.
And if we could do that,
I mean I really think we have a real
good chance of turning a lot of people
around. People that are
addicted to things, people
with psychological problems,
people who can't see themselves should
have a lot of, a lot of different issues.
And it's one of the best tools for that.
But like every tool, it could be abused,
but the problem is not the tool.
The problem is abuse,
whether it's with alcohol or pills
or food or any of these things.
We're talking about sex. People
can abuse anything, of course,
but doesn't mean that silicide and is in
an amazing compound that literally can
change humanity. It can. Yeah.
Yeah. It has. It has, and
there's so many other,
there's so many other things
that we don't even know.
We haven't even tapped
into the possibilities.
That's the other thing was when you
limit yourself on the possibilities,
it's like, well, we don't, how do we
know? How do you know what it's gonna do?
What if the chip releases
mushroom choose every 15 minutes?
A little microdose cheat? Just
a little micro dose it. No.
It feels your levels when
you start getting angry.
When the guy cuts me off and I'm like,
fuck,
aw, releases and I'm
like, a little bit of God.